rachel i feel like i have a very bad
case of whiplash where we're told you
know on the campaign trail president
trump where's your plan you don't have
one i've got one then there is no
federal government response and then
there's cleanup on aisle five with the
white house twitter feed the chief of
staff and finally president biden saying
he now has a federal plan it's just all
head spinning
yeah it's very schizophrenic and what's
interesting to me is that the latest
thing you know where he says no i really
do have a federal plan came in the form
of a tweet well what do you and i know
about about joe biden he's very old and
he's not tweeting um so somebody else is
tweeting this and that means that you
know we first of all it begs the
question who's in charge we have a right
to ask that question is it his staff is
there a cabal of you know valerie
jarrett and susan rice and obama people
doing it who is in charge we ought to
know that and two look um i don't blame
him for omicron i blame him for not
having the test but the fact is this is
a virus it spreads everyone's gonna get
it and the fact is that this
administration refuses to acknowledge
some basic facts that we have now
learned over two years there are natural
immunities we now know with omicron
there are some breakthroughs even with
natural immunity but especially with the
vax the vacs are the ones getting
omicron and spreading it the most so
this you know
vac's solution for everything is is
actually living in another era we need
to move forward this administration is
caught flat-footed and you're right
about one thing kaylee he criticized the
trump administration for not having
tests when this thing first started and
nobody should have expected the trump
administration to magically come up with
a bunch of tests but he was given a plan
in october he was told to order them and
he decided not to and
no one understands why and he should be
asked to respond to that why did you not
want to have tests when you knew this
variant was on its way
exactly molly he was given president
biden by president trump the most
advanced testing system in the world
this was a novel virus there were no
tests when president trump inherited
this when he got coven 19 you know in
the united states coming over from china
there were no tests he developed more
tests administered more tests than
western europe combined by last fall
that is impressive why didn't president
biden keep it up
well it's really important i think to go
back and think about what last year was
like before president the year before
president biden was made president and
you look at what happened when this
pandemic hits the world the trump
administration
does a bunch of stuff that they should
have done better but on the big stuff
they got everything right namely
developing these vaccines overcoming the
bureaucratic hurdles to get those
vaccines and by the time president biden
is inaugurated he has all the tools he
needs and this is important because he
claimed that the reason why you had to
vote for him was because he had some
magical mysterious plan to take care of
the global pandemic and in the end it's
been a year he's done literally nothing
other than use the vaccines that the
trump administration developed use the
protocols and the plans and the
procedures of the testing regime and
whatnot that the trump administration
developed and he's done nothing else and
the situation is so much worse than it
was when he took office and again the
entire case for his presidency was that
he had this plan and he was going to
squash the virus he's done nothing
he's done nothing tommy uh you know and
then
governors are rightfully saying hey
there's no federal response therefore
there are no federal mandates
but joe biden decides to go take a walk
on the beach with his new puppy
reporters managed to shout a few
questions at him one of which is
will you require vaccination in order to
have domestic air travel it seems like
it should be a pretty simple answer
no i'm not going to discriminate on who
can travel domestically vaccinated
versus unvaccinated but not so fast
president biden did not shut down the
idea let's roll the tape
decisions
stunning more mandates tommy
more mandates from the man who says he
has no federal solution but he wants to
bully the rest of us into compliance for
yet another year another year and a half
how long but when we're talking about
governors standing up that's exactly
what they need to do and there need to
be more especially those with ours
behind their name they all need to stand
up and speak truth to power especially
to this administration that has admitted
it has no plan but when we're talking
about these vaccine mandates i think
that that's where most americans are so
frustrated we know that getting the
vaccine one two three vaccines does not
prevent you from getting omicron or any
of the variants and it doesn't prevent
you from spreading it a vaccine is
personal it's to lessen your symptoms
and to increase your chances of survival
which we know that the mortality rates
are very low for omicron as we've seen
so far so it's a personal protection
this is another instance of the
government coming in as the nanny state
and telling you what you should do for
your personal health every time they try
to slam the unvaccinated for being
selfish it makes no sense because
getting the vaccine does not keep you
from passing it to somebody else so it's
about personal protection we need to get
that straight but i also have another
theory in why the testing was not
expanded when it should have been
because i think we can all agree we need
more tests i believe and this is my
personal belief that the biden
administration and the folks on his
medical team didn't want to expand the
testing because they didn't want to show
that the vaccinated were still getting
and giving coven i think that they
thought that that would discourage
vaccines so they wanted to lessen the
test or maybe not get as many as they
should have because they didn't want
people to realize oh boy maybe this
vaccine is not foolproof again that is
my personal belief but uh when you talk
about advising his medical team we all
know that he needs advisors we all know
we need to listen to scientists but i
don't ever remember electing dr fauci to
run my country but it seems like he is
and a lot of americans including myself
have a real problem with that
yeah it's a very scary prop prospect dr
fauci running the country but i agree
totally it seems like he is at times
brian you know public health and
confidence in public you know science
our institutions the cdc hhs it's really
important but when you look at all of
this in aggregate when you see biden
from a policy standpoint flipping
between i have no plan i have a plan and
then you look over at the science and dr
falchi to give an example says no mask
and then admits he said no mask at the
beginning of the pandemic because he
needed to save them for healthcare
workers and then he goes to one mask
then two masks then no mask if vax then
back to one mask no wonder people are
lacking faith in the science in dr
felchi
it's the tyranny of nonsense this is
impossible to navigate if you are a
business if you are a family if you are
a parent and you're trying to figure out
what does living life look like going
forward this president is resoundingly
unhelpful he got it right on monday he
was right on monday there is no federal
solution
this has to be handled at a state and a
local level but on tuesday his political
handlers got a hold of him and they said
mr president we can't do it that way
because it violates all of your promises
all of your promises that once again
never made sense
if we're going to get out of this we got
to get out from under the nonsense and
right now it is a noxious cloud hanging
over everything happening in this
country
it is rachel you know brian makes the
point he got it right tuesday that there
is no federal plan and you make the
point that we know he doesn't run his
own twitter uh or come up with his own
independent ideas so do you think two
was tuesday was just a rare candid
admission of the truth
yeah i think he does have a few lucid
moments and i think he threw his hands
up look there could also have been a
little bit of pass the buck let the
governors take the blame for why this is
is spreading but also i mean look at
he's on the beach wearing a mask
outdoors with his wife are they wearing
that in the bedroom i mean because if
they have to wear it outside on the
beach with the dog um i mean it's just
he sends so many mixed messages it
doesn't make any sense and again this is
the moment to talk about natural
immunity about early treatments about
other forms of of saving people besides
the vaccine because now we know the
vaccine is not going to protect you
doesn't matter if you have one two or
four jabs you can still get omicron and
it looks like they're the ones spreading
it the most right now